if you asked me today put fifty thousand  dollars on do aliens exist or not I'd  say they do not but that determination  on your part is almost entirely  theological part of it is I never got  into aliens even when I was an atheist I  was like yeah man I don't really think  there's aliens or anything it's like  because they'd always be like but the  universe is big and I was like well okay  whatever it's like it's big and sterile  I know you don't find the universe's big  argument to be compelling I think it is  because of just how we're talking about  100 billion galaxies or more in an  observable universe yeah 100 billion  galaxies 100 billion stars in each  Galaxy give or take yeah you know let's  say five or six planets on average  around each star how many planets does  that make yeah no I mean let's say  there's like a gazillion planets the  fact that there's a bunch of rocks does  not to me imply that there's a life on  any of